au départ j'étais pas très chaud pour
compass cette caméra cachée si j'avais
su je serais resté à ma première idée
parce que maintenant à chaque fois qu'on
me demande quelque chose dans la rue je
me sens obligé de démonter les fans
portable demain vous avez leur tout cela
bien sûr
j'aurais petite pièce pour
ces gentils
c'est des fois la halle aux jets au
boulot là tu me rappelles merci
[Musique]
c'est bien gentil monsieur
c'est con mais un ticket pain et de
manquer un france a un truc quand j'en
ai peu de syndiqués vous avez un
portable quoi vous avez pas les fous
pour acheter un ticket vous attendez
alors oui c'est pas bon merci fait la
manche c'est un portable ouais
maintenant je vaux plus rien pourquoi
pas les moyens d'avoir un portable non
non ça coûte cher tu as donné combien la
france j'ai qu'une fois non encore
encore
dit freddy bal dessus à coup sûr jumelé
hic c'est que je suis riche parce que je
joue pas là bas alors donnez moi une
tumeur si les
pompes pourquoi tu droite de la thune
comme ça pour jouer soit acheter à
manger à chaque fois des fruits pourquoi
ils sont pas bien si j'ai bien compris
que je donne pas il l'a fait et n'a pas
de portable non non comment qui fait
téléphone à
lui rappelé que le partage de nos jours
ben moi je parle pas bien la langue
non pas savoir par les haras pour
moi l'autre et ça arrive au bout du
monde
moi non plus je vais pas acheter un
jeu acheté chez court vite
court vite c'est tu le prends et tu
cours vite
un joli vous avez une peine qui est 100
alors tu fais lambrusco porte cachée au
boulot te rappelles toi tu peux donc
c'était un portable ouais pourquoi
je sais pas c'est forfait à 300 francs
en fout bah oui à mon ami serait pas une
petite pièce pour prendre mon train s'il
vous plaît c'est pas parce qu'un seul
ils n'ont pas saisi ce pas parce qu'un
suivi mme pascale quoi pascal sellem
combien ça coûte
il manque deux ou trois bons combien ça
coûte combien j'aime bien votre émission
merci alors allez au revoir c'est ça
ouais c'est ça enfin presque
[Musique]